oh putainoi c'est combien qu'est- qu'il
y 5 millions 5 milli on va avoir la vie
qu'on mérite avec
5li bienvenue au tirage top million de
ce jeudi allez c'est parti pour le
tirage de ce soir Mo que je me casse de
ce morir avonsnous ce soir un gagnant le
1 j'arrive pas à réaliser j'ai pas dormi
de la nuit et oui nous avons un grand
gagnant ce soir on a gagné 6 millions
non c'est pas
[Musique]
ça va là tu es multimillionnaire depuis
même pas 10 minutes et ça ça te rentre
dedans on divise en trois ouais alors
après c'est quand même Monti là ouais
depuis que je FR est rentré dans nos
vies le mal Blin audessus de nous on est
riche maintenant il est riche il s' sort
de tout toujours attends attends attends
il il y a pas une date limite c'est
aujourd'hui allez combien pour que tu
admett que tu es une petite
[Musique]
dismoi combien apr on va
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
voil ils ont ditant de but faire tourner
comme P
des je sais Mme pas ce que ça veut
dire